[Música]
cuando vemos una película o una obra de
teatro sabemos que los actores
probablemente aprendieron un guión que
esencialmente les dice que decir y
cuando decirlo una pieza musical
funciona bajo el mismo principio de una
manera bastante sencilla le dice al
músico que cuando tocar estéticamente
hablando existe una enorme diferencia
entre digamos beethoven y justin bieber
pero ambos artistas usaron los mismos
ladrillos para crear su música las notas
y si bien el resultado final puede sonar
un poco complicado la lógica detrás de
las notas musicales es bastante sencilla
démosle un vistazo a los elementos
fundamentales de la notación musical ya
cómo interactúan para crear una obra de
arte la música se escribe sobre cinco
líneas paralelas horizontales estas
cinco líneas se llaman pentagrama el
pentagrama funciona en dos ejes de
arriba a abajo y de izquierda a derecha
el eje vertical le indica al músico el
tono de la nota es decir qué nota tocar
y el eje horizontal el ritmo de la nota
es decir cuando tocar comencemos con el
tono
para ayudarnos vamos a usar un piano
pero el sistema funciona prácticamente
con cualquier instrumento que puedan
imaginarse en la tradición musical de
occidente los tonos llevan el nombre de
las siete primeras letras del alfabeto
b c d e f y g
después el ciclo se repite a b c d e f g
abs d e f g y así pero de donde obtienen
los tonos sus nombres bueno por ejemplo
si tocaras un f fa y luego tocará otro
efe fa más arriba o más abajo en el
piano te darías cuenta que suenan
bastante parecido en comparación a
digamos un b si volviendo al pentagrama
cada línea y cada espacio entre dos
líneas representan un tono por separado
si ponemos una nota en una de estas
líneas o uno de estos espacios le
estamos diciendo al músico que toque ese
tono mientras más alta está ubicada la
nota en el pentagrama más alto será el
tono pero obviamente existen muchos
muchos más tonos que los nueve que nos
dan estas líneas y espacios en un piano
de cola por ejemplo se pueden tocar
ochenta y ocho notas distintas entonces
como metemos ochenta y ocho notas en un
solo pentagrama usamos algo llamado
clave
una clave es una figura extraña que se
ubica al principio del pentagrama que
actúa como punto de referencia y que
dice que una línea o espacio particular
corresponde a una nota específica en el
instrumento si queremos tocar las notas
que no se encuentran en el pentagrama
hacemos un poco de trampa y agregamos
pequeñas líneas llamadas auxiliares para
ubicar las notas en ellas sí necesitamos
demasiadas líneas auxiliares que se
torna confuso entonces cambiamos a otra
clave
para cuando tocar las notas existen dos
elementos que controlan esto el tiempo y
el ritmo
el tiempo de una obra es en sí un poco
aburrido suena algo así
habrás notado que no cambia se mantiene
de manera constante puede ir despacio
o rápido o como quieras en serio el
punto es que como la manecilla de los
segundos en un reloj divide un minuto en
60 segundos cada segundo tan largo como
todos los otros el tiempo divide una
pieza musical en pequeños fragmentos de
tiempo que tienen todos la misma
duración tiempos con un tiempo constante
como base podemos empezar a agregarle
ritmo a nuestras notas y es ahí cuando
la música realmente ocurre esto es una
negra la unidad más básica de ritmo y
vale un tiempo
esto es una blanca y vale dos tiempos
esto es una redonda y vale cuatro
tiempos y estas pequeñitas se llaman
corcheas y valen medio tiempo cada una
genial pero qué significa eso dirás te
habrás dado cuenta que en un pentagrama
existen pequeñas líneas que lo dividen
en secciones más pequeñas las líneas
divisorias y cada sección es un compás
al comienzo de una pieza musical justo
después de la clave está la fórmula del
compás que indica cuántos tiempos hay en
cada compás este dice que hay dos
tiempos en cada compás aquí dice que hay
tres este cuatro y así el número de
abajo nos dice qué tipo de notas debe
ser usada como unidad básica de tiempo
el 1 corresponde a una redonda el 2 a
una blanca el 4 a una negra y el 8 a una
corchea y así por lo que esta fórmula de
compás nos dice que hay 4 negras en cada
compás 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 y así pero como
dije antes si solo nos atenemos al
tiempo se torna un poco aburrido por lo
que cambiaremos algunas negras por otras
figuras aquí si bien el número de notas
en cada compás ha cambiado el número
total de tiempos en cada compás es el
mismo
entonces cómo suena nuestra creación
musical
suena bien pero quizás un poco vacía no
agreguemos otro instrumento con su
propio tono y ritmo
ahora sí que suena como música
seguro acostumbrarse a leer rápidamente
requiere un poco de práctica y también
tocarlo en nuestro instrumento pero con
algo de tiempo y paciencia podría ser el
próximo beethoven 8 steam bieber
suscríbase a nuestro canal y continúe
incorporando conocimientos nuevos con
ted ed en español donde encontrará
animaciones sobre todo tipo de temas
desde cómo mejorar su pensamiento
crítico hasta cómo aprender a resolver
enigmas complicados tenga curiosidad y
manténgase conectado